hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast navigating abducted and
duck loose team hoods which is better
presented by best manga Meyer sales
engineer I'm Alexis Krause of laberd's
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab route and
sponsored by lab không có for more
information on our sponsor please visit
lab Tomko comm now let's get started
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click on
the send button once there's many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window click on the arrows
at the top right hand corner of the
slide window if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on
answer question box located on the far
left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit
I'd like to now introduce our presenter
Beth make Meyer fast mag Mayer is the
sales engineer for chemical fume hoods
at Balad chemical corporation a leading
manufacturer of laboratory ventilation
equipment Beth has presented multiple
times at the American industrial hygiene
conference and exposition and at Pitt
cone before joining lab Congo in 2013
Beth was a Business Development Manager
at Ruskin company where she focused on
the manufacturing of louvers at the HVAC
industry and architectural products
she holds degrees from the University of
Kansas and University of Saint Mary Bess
is a construction documents technologist
certified by the construction
specifications Institute and a LEED
Green Associate best you may now begin
your presentation
thank you hello everyone I want to thank
you all for joining my webinar today on
navigating ducted and ductless fume
hoods so during today's discussion we
are going to be talking about chemical
fume hoods in other words were only
talking about the hoods that are
protecting personnel from harmful
chemical fumes and vapors these are not
biological safety cabinets and they are
not powder hoods those would actually be
completely different pieces of equipment
so if you're in need of some assistance
on powder or biological hoods just email
me and I can get you to the application
specialist that covers those products so
here's our map of what we're actually
going to be talking about today under
the umbrella term fume hoods we have
ducted in ductless hoods and we're going
to be exploring the different types of
hoods that go under these terms and one
thing I do want to mention before
starting is I know that during a webinar
it's easy to listen to the first 10
minutes and be distracted and go off and
answer emails and do other things so I
do want to say if you want the full
benefit of this webinar you have to
stick with me to the end because I'll be
discussing only ducted hoods for a bit
and then only dustless and then we're
going to combine them so if you don't
have time to listen to the whole webinar
right now I do suggest coming back and
listening to the recording on when you
have time later otherwise you may only
get information on the ducted hoods if
you're only listening to the first
portion of it alrighty so it's no
surprise that people need training on
this subject I'm showing this slide to
illustrate all the different hoods
Levchenko offers that fit into these two
categories so you can see it's not a
small number each of these hoods is
appropriate for a different reason and
this webinar is going to help you
navigate the first step of choosing to
go either ducted or ductless
so going back to our map from before
first we're going to dig into ducted
hoods and explore what kind of cost you
can expect with going with a ducted
system and what the difference is
between a remote blower and a built in
blower and then we're going to go and
dig into ductless and filter hoods and
then look at the different definitions
which there are three and how to choose
between them and then we're going to
come back together and compare the two
options to find out which will be better
in what application and why so what
we're looking at here is the most common
duct layout it's a rower configuration
in this image starting with the hood and
moving up we have the ductwork
connection on the top of the hood and
then we have a 90-degree elbow somewhere
in that duct run since the inlet to the
blower is on the side and then we have
the remote lower that's located most
often on the rooftop and then a vertical
outlet that has a zero pressure weather
cap as the termination what you see
there these blowers they have to be
sized for their duct run and fume hood
design the air that's going through the
fume hood is completely controlled by
that blower so if you have a constant
air volume system or CA V for short
where the air being exhausted through
the hood is the same regardless of the
sash position then that means the blower
does not change speeds and if you have a
variable air volume system or Vav for
short where the air being exhausted
through the hood is different depending
on the sash position that means the fan
either changes speeds or that there are
valves in the system that open and close
to modify the supply and exhaust air
volume to keep that room in balance with
the changing sash position so then in
this kind of configuration one remote
blower can operate more than one fume
hood that's the beauty of the remote
blower configuration you can size the
blower for whatever the hood and the
duct run needs and the reason that this
is the most popular installation is
because all the ductwork is kept
negative pressure meaning if you were to
get a leak in the duct run somewhere
between the hood and the blower and
let's say that ductwork goes through an
occupied office space then the fan
suction will actually pull air through
the leak not allowing those harmful
vapors to travel out of the leak so this
is what a typical rooftop installation
looks like with a remote blower the
ductwork goes into the inlet of the
blower on the side and then you have the
zero pressure weather cap on top to
allow the air to exhaust vertically and
be taken away and diluted so now we're
going to look at the built in blower
configuration where the blower is
actually sitting right on top of the
fume hood pushing the air up this duct
run can go directly vertical but on this
version you can't size the blower the
blower is built in so you need to make
sure your duct run is appropriate for
the blower fan curve these are typically
louder because your fan is right on top
of the fume hood so I wouldn't recommend
these for teaching labs or any lab where
noise is a factor and finally the
biggest reason against using a built in
blower configuration is that it puts all
of the ductwork under positive pressure
so that entire length of duct from a
fume hood up to the termination if
having air pushed through it rather than
being pulled in the previous example the
biggest difference is if there were to
be a leak in this duct work and that
duct run were going through an occupied
office space then the contaminated air
going through that ductwork would
actually leak out into that space so I
always say start with the remote blower
configuration and if you absolutely
can't make that work and you have a
short direct duct run then go for the
built in blower um this this lower
configuration does have its time in
place so what the ideal applications are
for mobile lab spaces or
single-story buildings with a pitched
roof where it would really be difficult
to install a promote blower on the
rooftop and if you have a built-in
blower just make sure that you check the
duct run regularly for leaks and patch
them up right away it is important to do
so
so the typical cost associated with
ducted systems of course have to do with
ducting the hood out and the actual
equipment and then the annual energy
usage cost the upfront costs include the
hood and the ductwork and the exhaust
fan and the extra tonnage required to
air-condition the air that you'll be put
exhausting outside via the hood and the
installation which could mean putting
holes in walls and the roof if they
aren't there already and that can be
very costly so just to put some numbers
to what we're talking about you can plan
to spend about ten thousand dollars on a
typical fume hood assembly and then
added on to that is your infrastructure
so your blower the ductwork the air
handling units the installation and this
could all start at about 20,000 but
honestly I've seen upwards of 50,000 for
a tricky building and then if you put
sophisticated controls on your building
like a Vav system it could be upwards of
a hundred thousand so this number is
incredibly variable these are the
start-up costs and one way to lower
these numbers is to use a
high-performance fume hood that doesn't
require as much CFM or air as a typical
hood but that's a whole other topic in
itself so to keep it simple I'll just
say that the lower the CFM the lower
your upfront bill and the lower your
annual bill so if you'd like to know
more about what a high-performance hood
is you can always email me and I'll be
happy to discuss that energy costs are
going to vary also depending on where
you live so the folks in the Northeast
United States have higher bills than in
the Midwest so we typically estimate a
dollars to $13 per CFM per year
or the fume hood annual energy costs and
that a fume hood operating all the time
so so on a typical six-foot hood it
would be about five to nine thousand
dollars depending on if it's a
high-performance and what the required
face velocity of your facility is
so if you're looking to save some money
and you are using a ducted fume hood
here are some other figures to
illustrate what you can do or what
decisions you can make in order to lower
that annual bill so just switching to a
high-performance hood can reduce your
air consumption by 40 to 60% for larger
labs with at least 10 fume hoods you
could use a variable air volume hood or
Vav where the amount of air changes the
amount of exhausted air changes as the
sash goes up and down so you can lower
your air consumption by 10 to 75% and
you might be thinking that's a really
huge difference in numbers but that that
number has a really large range because
in order to be effective the sash has to
be lowered on a Vav system if it's never
closed then you never see a change in
the air being exhausted so it acts just
like a constant volume hood if that sash
has never moved so that brings us to the
best-case scenario using a high
performance hood that is on a Vav system
and have sash intelligence which means
that the hood has a motion sensor to
detect a person's presence and if the
sensor doesn't detect motion then the
sash will shut and you'll reap all the
benefits of the lower CFM those can save
at least 90 percent of the required air
consumption compared to a standard fume
hood operating a constant volume so for
smaller labs that have less than 10 fume
hoods there are more inexpensive
solutions for you that include multi
speed blowers like the intellisense
blower that blower can be set up with up
to three different speeds so at the end
of the day you can have a nice set back
option and exhaust less air at night yet
still keeping the hood under slight
negative pressure to prevent back
drafting explosion-proof fume hoods are
actually a webinar in themselves but I
did want to bring them up because the
bottom line is if you need an
explosion-proof hood
must be deducted so just remember that
and you're good to go for purposes of
this webinar
so here we are back to our map and now
we're going to talk about ductless hoods
and we're going to go over the
definitions and the cost implications
for those hoods and then stick with me
and we'll go over the considerations
when choosing what type of hood to use
so you might be wondering what a
dinosaur has to do with ductless hoods
like what's shown in this image so this
is actually an image of the Denver
Museum of Nature and Science and they
have a specimen curation lab directly
under this dinosaur illustrating our
first reason why you might want a
ductless hood because the dinosaur
wouldn't be too pretty with ductwork
going through the exhibit right so we'll
get into some more applications later
but basically these dustless hoods get
their name because of a carbon filter
pack located above the fume hood that
cleans the air before recirculating it
back to the lab they require no ductwork
whatsoever so you might be thinking just
perfect that sounds easy let's do it
well we're going to learn about the
reasons why you wouldn't want wouldn't
want to use these in your lab so we're
going to start with the definitions
given by FIFA which is the scientific
equipment and furniture Association so
first with dh1 hoods and eh does
stanford ductless hood so dh1 hoods are
for nuisance vapors or non hazardous
chemistry so these are typically smaller
enclosures and they don't have sensors
as a standard item so the ways to tell
when to change these filters out is by
your nose so that means you can't use
anything hazardous so these enclosures
will have application-specific filters
like ammonia or fill out formaldehyde or
organic vapors so typical applications
for these are staining or cover slipping
or anything you would really do on an
open bench that might be smelly so from
lab Kenko these enclosures are called
the fume absorber which is the photo on
the left and the
or workstation which is the photo on the
right and after every one of these
definitions I'm just going to give a
quick recap so in a nutshell the dh1 is
just for nuisance papers there isn't a
censor as a standard and these are for
applications you would do on an open
bench so on to the next one
dh2 hoods they actually do have a sensor
on top of the filter stack so it does
have the safety feature of that sensor
however once that sensor goes off the
filters need to be replaced because if
you think about it the sensors on top of
the filters and what's beyond that it's
just the lab air so once that sensor
goes off those contaminants are entering
the lab error so the dh2 enclosures also
have application-specific filters just
like the dh1 hood and since these have a
sensor on top of the filters these are
best with repeatable processes when you
can really tell how long the filters are
going to last so if there's a
limited-use application that is
repeatable and you don't really need
service fixtures or electrical outlets
then this is the perfect hood for you
you can have minimal service fixtures
you could Dec mount them inside the hood
but it does take away you know your
precious real estate inside the hood so
it's ideal for those applications that
don't really need service fixtures or
electrical outlets the lab con Cody h2
model is called the Paramount which is
shown in this image so another quick
rundown these are great for repeatable
processes they have a sensor located
above the filters and they use chemical
specific filters so that's the D h2
then the finally the third definition is
a lab Khan code the h3 hood it's
actually a marriage of products between
lab Camco and earl ab who's another
manufacturer using our lab screen fume
hood technology and we refer to this as
a filtered fume hood to differentiate B
because the specific product is so
different from the dh1 d h2 and even the
minimum requirements of dh3 this hood
has a sensor in between the primary and
secondary filter so when the sensor goes
off you have an entire backup filter
that is the same size and efficacy as
the primary filter so size-wise the hood
and the filters are larger each filter
is about three times the size of the D H
1 or D H 2 filters so just by sheer
volume they have more carbon and
therefore these filters are going to
last longer because they have greater
capacity so this hood has also has
corner post so you can install service
fixtures and electrical duplexes so it's
as close as you can get to being a
general chemistry fume hood without
ducting out it also has a fully
functioning sash that slides up and down
unlike the other enclosures that have a
sash that lifts up towards the user like
a hatchback so these would require one
type of filter unlike the other D H
families that both have the chemical
specific filters dh3 hoods this this
hood that we offer requires only one
type of filter and it's called a nutria
dine filter which is the filter that our
lab offers it's still a carbon filter
but it's activated differently and is
able to filter out acids bases and
solvents and the final difference is the
D h3 hood has the control board attached
to the face and it's basically a
computer and it tracks the sash position
fan speeds alarms and even the user
which is based upon RFID cards that are
provided with the hood
so overall the echo and arrow
which are the lab combo offerings for
this hood is a more sophisticated
enclosure but with the sophistication
comes more user responsibilities which
we'll get into in more detail and once
again lab con Co has two hoods that fall
into this category the echo and the
arrow so the quick rundown here is the
dh3 is the closest thing to a general
chemistry fume hood without being ducted
out since they can filter out acids
bases and solvents at the same time and
it can house serviced fixtures and
electrical duplexes on the corner post
it has the sensor in the middle of the
primary and secondary filter so you have
a backup for when the alarm goes off
telling you your filters need to be
changed so something that actually
applies to all of the types of hoods
that we just learned about is that there
are some bad actors when it comes to
chemical compatibility with carbon
filters and most importantly these
aren't chemicals that are considered
extremely hazardous for the most part
it's the low molecular weight solvents
that are not a good fit for carbon
filtration because they all have very
low filter capacities in other words the
filters will fill up very quickly
sometimes even on the same day of use so
those chemicals are listed here at the
tone ethanol methanol and a seed in
nitrile therefore any time you have a
cleaning application with acetone that's
going to be thrown out of contention
right away because it's just going to be
too much of it to work with the filters
and it will evaporate and fill up the
filter too quickly but if you're working
with these in limited quantities limited
volumes or you can close the container
that they are in most of the time then
it might still work so the goal here is
to limit the evaporation of these
chemicals so if you can do that then
ductless may still be an option for you
and no duplicate can capture every
chemical so before you can consider one
of these hoods you'll have to fill out a
chemical assessment form to make sure
that your application is compatible with
the filtration so this is always step
one in the process and it's going to ask
for things like the type of handling the
chemical names the type of containers
whether it is open or closed the
dilution percentage the temperature the
handling frequency quantity and duration
of use so when looking at the lifetime
use take into account if an application
changes you will need to resubmit that
application to the manufacturer on a new
chemical assessment form to make sure
that it's appropriate and the
maintenance conversation is always an
important one with any type of ductless
or filtered fume hood because
maintenance is inevitable with these
hoods so people who are used to working
with ducted hoods they get used to not
really having to touch anything in order
to work with the hood it's pretty much a
set it and forget it type of situation
but on a ductless side there will be
alarms and they're not typical and
adducted fume hood so the lab personnel
really needs to be properly trained on
what to do in the event of an alarm and
someone at the facility or a pre-planned
third party needs to be able to service
the hood and perform filter changes and
also on our dh3 hood the echo and arrow
there is an acid sensor change out that
needs to be done every two years so the
alarm will go off and the maintenance
will need to be done in order to
continue to have a safe enclosure
also filters have a cost and a
maintenance requirement so depending on
what type of ductless hood you have the
filter could range anywhere from a
couple hundred bucks to about a thousand
dollars each and each hood can have
anywhere from two to ten filters so this
has to be a part of your cost and
benefit analysis to look at filter costs
based on how many times you will change
them which you'll find out with your
chemical assessment results and figuring
out who at your facility will do this or
will you need to outsource it
the filters may also be considered
hazardous waste so that will have to be
taken into consideration as well with
the cost so with a D H 1 or D H 2 the
filters might last up to six months with
an ideal application and with the D H 3
the filters might last up to two years
or maybe even longer with a truly ideal
application
the cost associated with ductless hoods
include the first cost which have a very
large range because the dh3
can do much more than a dh1 so the range
for purposes of comparing with a fume
hood start at 10,000 and go to 30000 for
the actual hood just as an estimate then
we have the filters which could range
from 500 to 10,000 per hood depending on
the size of the hood and what kind of
hood you have so the building
infrastructure it's not going to be
included since you don't have to cut any
holes or install a blower on the rooftop
installation may cost more for one of
these hoods since the filters there are
filters and modules to unpack and
install and would not be included on a
typical fume hood set up so that all has
to be considered this photo here shows a
palette of 16 filters so when you're
looking at the installation keep in mind
the opening of all of these individual
boxes and the disposal and the
organization and all of that just takes
time and labor and adds to the cost and
you'll want to make sure that the
different traits that are hired to
install know what is in their scope so
the full installation is completed some
contractors will just see fume hood
installation to bid and they might take
that to mean placing the hood in its
place and leaving and that doesn't
include the whole package especially on
the D h2 and the D h3 meaning your fume
hood could be left half installed so
you're in the good news is though your
annual costs are going to be comprised
of $0 in energy costs at least from the
air-conditioning since you're recycling
the room air so you really only worry
about the power to plug the hood in
which is really minimal so your real
costs are the filters which it's always
the golden question how long are my
filters going to last and you'll never
be able to get a great answer until that
chemical assessment form is filled out
so that's why we always say that's step
one of the entire process if you're
really serious about
ductless you need to fill out a chemical
assessment form so we estimate the
filter cost to be six hundred to five
thousand annually and disposable Duns
our disposal would be part of this cost
as well and any other costs associated
will be from maintenance which would be
the labor to perform the filter changes
and the sensor changes on the dh3 Andrey
commissioned the hood after the filters
are changed
so here are some other differences
between the D h2 d h3 and versus a
ducted hood
so a typical ducted hood has minimal
maintenance after its installed the
infrastructure and the remote ler might
take some extra effort at the start but
once they're set you won't need to think
about them for a while and with the
ductless hood the user has to be trained
to know what to do for different error
codes and there needs to be a back-up
plan in place for when the filters need
to be changed on a ductless hood then
you have the maintenance of the filter
change out with a ducted hood the user
can be a little bit more lenient with
the chemicals used you don't have to
worry about filling up filters or even B
not being able to use certain chemicals
at all the worst that can happen with a
ducted fume hood is your fume hood liner
will corrode and you'll have to replace
your fume hood but that won't likely
happen in a quick scenario so you'll
have plenty of warning before that would
need to happen you won't have to worry
about your filter having break through
and possibly stopping the work before
it's complete as long as the blower is
going the fume hood should really be
doing its job a ducted hood can act as a
laboratory exhaust to meet your minimum
air changes per hour so just like any
other building there's a minimum air
change rate in a lab which is how many
times the air renews in a space
adding a desolated will not contribute
to this air exchange rate and therefore
that exhaust may have to come from
another source like a general room
exhaust so if your intent is to save
money look to see if your minimum air
changes are met first because you may
have to exhaust out anyway so now we're
going to go through different questions
to consider while looking at both
deducted and the ductless hoods and
we'll find out by going through these
questions which enclosure will be better
for which application so some of these
might meet your application exactly and
it will give you the answer of whether
or not to go ducted or ductless first is
the general application good for a
ductless hood as the manufacturer
reviewed the application and actually
told you it's approved any manufacturer
who offers a ductless fume hood will be
able to review an application and tell
you if it's approved and how long they
expect the filters to last how often do
your filters need to be replaced
so once again the manufacturer will tell
you this information after you fill out
your chemical assessment form if it's a
short filter life is it even worth the
cost of changing those filters out
versus the installation and energy costs
of your ducted fume hood
you'll have to weigh that on a
case-by-case basis does your room have a
sufficient air gap what this means is
the the area above the fume hood there
needs to be a three to four inch air gap
above the filters and this does include
any accessory HEPA filters so if you
ever need to check if height is
appropriate call the manufacturer to
double-check if you don't have this air
gap the air won't have the chance to
recirculate in the room and your room
air balance could be affected so you
really want to make sure that there's an
air gap so that the air can recycle into
the lab do you rent or own your space
so sometimes owners don't want you
putting holes in their walls and roof so
if
definitely something to consider if you
if you're allowed to put holes for a
ducted hood or if you're you know pushed
more into using a ductless solution
because you don't have to put any holes
in the wall
do you want to vent chemical storage
under the hood so this is really an
important question that gets overlooked
because you can really only event acid
cabinets through a dh3 fume hood any
other Sinnott scenario would have to be
a ducted hood meaning if you want to
vent a solvent cabinet it has to be
connected to a negatively pressure duct
above the fume hood so if you have a D H
1 or D H 2 you can't vent anything that
is a solvent cabinet so the other
consideration is that any acid vented
into the D H 3 hood does contribute to
the filters loading up so those would
have to be on the chemical assessment
form as well and here is an image of the
way these cabinets vent into the fume
hood so if your ducting out you can vent
a solvent cabinet connected to the
ductwork above and once again this has
to be negatively pressured duct so it
has to be with the remote blower setup
that we saw in the very beginning of
this presentation not a built in blower
setup and the acid cabinet on the Left
shows how those are vented in the fume
hood with the connection through the
work surface
and here we have more consideration so
first who's going to install the hood if
you have a ductless hood make sure the
installer scope includes more than just
placing the hood on the surface you have
to tell them that they have to install
the components above the hood which
includes stacking the filters and the
light and the fan boxes on the dh3 hood
and that includes unpacking everything
that needs to be stacked and also
commissioning after its installed
so you need to budget extra time for
this and troubleshooting if there's any
issues in the meantime and for abducted
hood those are covered by different
trades so a mechanical contractor
usually does the ductwork and you might
have a different trade actually put the
hood in place it's and then you might
have a plumber to plumb your service
fixtures into the hood so it's all
things that you want to make sure to
have covered before choosing which had
to go with who is going to change the
filters will this be someone at your
facility will this be a third party
basically you just need to plan ahead
and make sure you know who it's going to
be before purchasing a hood can the hood
fit through a doorway this goes actually
producted or ductless but the reason I'm
specifically saying this is the typical
dh3 is 43 inches deep so you would need
a 43 inch wide doorway to fit through
and they can be disassembled but once
again that adds till installation time
so the hoods the hoods are sent with
everything assembled but it can be
disassembled to fit through a doorway so
make sure it can either fit or someone
is there to disassemble and reassemble
the hood
and here's the last slide of
consideration are you aware of the
maintenance that's required and this is
a common theme but we often find people
are not aware and and they're really
unhappy when they're not aware and we
really don't like unhappy customers we
want to make sure everyone has the
correct expectations of what they're
going to get and and knows what they're
getting into so I really try and make
this clear second if you remember from
before if you need an explosion-proof
hood it has to be ducted period there is
not an explosion-proof ductless hood on
the market so explosion-proof always
equals ducted is this the only hood in
the lab if so I strongly suggest going
ducted what that's going to do is
contribute to the air exchange rate and
also you don't have to worry about being
super careful with what you put into the
hood also think about it five years down
the road
this hood might be perfect for you but
in a couple years you might change up
what you're doing and find out that one
of the chemicals you're working with is
not compatible with a ductless or
filtered fume hood and so you have to go
ducted anyway so if this is the only
hood in the lab I really strongly
suggest going ducted are you replacing a
ducted hood and as the duct run already
installed if so that's really one of the
most difficult pieces of the
installations for a ducted hood so I
suggest duct it because a huge chunk of
money
included with ducted hoods is the duct
run installation so you've already won
half the battle are you relocating soon
if so you might want to consider
ductless because they are obviously
easier to transport to different labs
there are if you're renovating a lab
it's kind of a popular trend to do a
temporary lab with some ductless or
filtered hoods and then when you're
building the your permit
lab to integrate those duck lips and
filtered hoods into a ducted hood
scenario and so that way you're cutting
down on the amount of air that you're
having to exhaust so don't forget you
can always mix and match as well with
the hoods our people in your lab
educated to know what they cannot use in
a specific hood is your facility one
that has a lot of turnover if you have a
stable workforce and they can be trained
for the equipment then ductless is
definitely an option if you have high
turnover and it's hard to keep people
educated on the equipment
I suggest ducted just because it is you
won't have all the alarms that might
happen with a ductless hood ok so we got
through the questions and considerations
now let's talk some pros and cons
Douglass's are very flexible so if
you're going to move or you want to use
the hood in a different lab space or
multiple lab spaces ductless hoods can
be moved since they aren't connected to
ductwork dh2 hoods are easier to move
than dh3 just because of the sheer size
so make sure if you are going to move
something make sure that your doorways
have the dimensions too to accept that
also the Douglases are turn-key meaning
the installation is of the actual hood
is easier for the most part because you
basically set the hood up and then you
have to set up the filters you don't
have to cut holes in any walls or roofs
and so that doesn't have an added cost
for you they are portable and they are
sustainable since they use less energy
you don't have to take all the air
conditioned air out of a lab to use them
and they are green they don't send
chemical fumes outside like a typical
ducted fume hood they're trapping them
in a filter and it gets disposed of so
now for the cons they can be noisier
than you'd like
since the fan modules are right above
the fume hood maintenance is inevitable
there are limited applications that can
be used with them you
not every application is going to be
able to be used in a ductless hood and
there's a risk of chemical exposure with
the D h1 and d h2 and even dh3
if you go through the backup filters
people really need to pay attention to
the alarms that go off with these hoods
and there has to be a successful
training in order to have the successful
implementation in your lab so here are
the scenarios where you would absolutely
want to use ducted hoods any specialty
application with perchloric acid acid
digestion or hydrofluoric acid use those
will not work with a ductless or
filtered hood once again if you need
explosion proof construction you have to
go ducted if you want a low maintenance
hood I'd go ducted if you're working
with highly exothermic reactions that
give off a lot of heat or smoke you need
to go ducted and the rest are specific
chemicals that you don't want to use um
you know which include mercury
insecticides hydrogen cyanide and the
four bad actors we spoke about before
acetone ethanol methanol and a seeded I
trial in high volumes and here are the
times when it would be completely
acceptable to go ductless so if you have
a repeated protocol with little
variation what you're doing and what
you'll be doing in the future so always
think about the future because this is a
piece of capital equipment that you're
going to invest a lot of money in so
it's important to know that it will work
for you for a while also when installing
ductwork is simply not feasible you know
think of the dinosaur application before
at the Denver Museum they they didn't
have anywhere to put the ductwork they
had a lab right below the dinosaur or
maybe you don't own your own space and
you might be in the basement of a
15-story building if the lab already has
a ductless fume hood but requires
additional work space that's also a
great application for a ductless hood
you always have the ducted hood to fall
back on if the lab works with non
hazardous chemicals or the chemicals are
used in non hazardous volumes or
concentrations that's a great ductless
application if the lab needs to be
mobile the at the example of moving in
the near future it might benefit you to
go ductless since it's easier to move
without the connections to the building
or you know you don't have to put any
holes in the roof and last item is when
training is available and your workforce
is stable and you feel comfortable with
everyone knowing what to do in a
ductless hood so for the last slide just
sum up this to sum up we have a decision
decision tree that we've been developing
so you're not working with biological
samples obviously these are just
chemical fume hoods next you don't have
any specialty applications which is
which are what these parts of the
decision tree are which these are the
ones that are showing up our perchloric
acid acid digestion and radioisotope you
always have to go ducted with those and
finally to finish it off if you're
interested in saving money because you
don't have to exhaust out and if your
application is appropriate for a
ductless hood then by all means you can
consider it so I hope you guys have all
enjoyed this webinar and thanks for
sticking with me the whole time if you
have any questions at all please send
them in or if you have to take off
please feel free to email me at best em
at lab con cocom and right now I'll open
it up to some questions
Thank You Beth for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now this click on the answer question
box located on the far left to your
screen and will answer many four
questions as we have time for so let's
get started
our first question is how do I get a
chemical assessment form well that's a
good question there's a couple different
ways to get a chemical assessment form
the first is you can always email me my
email is just best M at lab Kenko comm
so be ETH and like Mary at lab can cocom
and I can send it out on lab compo comm
the website you can actually fill one
out online and submit it online and you
do need to register to have an account
but that is also a very easy way because
then just gets submitted automatically
and then you'll get an answer within a
couple days
our next questions on a Vav system what
stays constant
okay so on a Vav system which to remind
everyone Vav stands for variable air
volume what stays constant typically
people set those systems so that the
face velocity stays constant so the feet
per minute measurement so a lot of times
you'll see you know when the sash is
fully open you'll have the hood set to
100 feet per minute and then if you
lower it to a 18 inch open the over the
work surface then that would also scale
down the CFM or the cubic feet per
minute so that the feet per minute also
equals 100 feet per minute and then when
you lower it about 6 inches off the work
surface it would also be it would also
be 100 feet per minute so on a Vav
system the face velocity stays constant
and then on a flip side on a constant
volume system the just like it sounds
the volume stays constant or the CFM
stays constant
and that's why why do you say zero
dollar energy costs on a ductless system
it still has fans and lights that
consume energy sure so when we're
looking at at a fumehood system in
general when we are looking at how much
air it's pumping out that's really the
huge significant portion of your energy
costs so while you do still have fans
and lights those are very very minimal
so we actually can round those down to
zero pretty much it'll be just a couple
dollars a year as compared to when
you're looking at the air that's being
pumped out of the building in a ducted
system that's going to be if the hood is
on all the time you can like we
discussed in this presentation it would
be about at least eight dollars per CFM
per year depending on where where you
live and what hood you have so we do
round down to zero dollars energy costs
on the ductless system because we aren't
sending any of that air outside and
therefore we do round down for that
because when you compare the two costs
the fans and the lights just they
basically consume no energy compared to
compared to the air that gets air
conditioned and then sent outside
you
we are getting some interesting
questions in here so let's see if we can
maybe have time for one more
you
you
so our low-flow excuse me our low-flow
fume hoods appropriate for all
applications and what is the typical
inflow and exhaust CFM for lab Congo's 8
8 foot model so ok so the first part of
that question our low-flow hood
appropriate for all applications they
would be appropriate for most
applications and and that's speaking in
terms of actually running the hood at a
lower face velocity so like for example
we have some specialty hoods at lab conk
Oh like a acid digestion hood well the
acid digestion hood actually has the
same design features as a low-flow hood
however with acid digestion we don't
recommend operating it at 60 feet per
minute just because with acid digestion
there's typically a lot of heat involved
and you want to keep that face velocity
higher in order to cool the air down
inside the hood so there's situations
like that for you know typical basically
typical heads versus the specialty
application has where you might actually
have an industry standard that spells
out on a specialty application hood what
it needs to be operated at so you know I
think that's kind of a roundabout way to
answer that question but for general
chemistry applications absolutely
low-flow heads are appropriate for all
of those applications for the specialty
applications you can use the low flow
features but you might not operate the
hood actually at at that low flat like
60 feet per minute then the second part
of that the typical exhaust for the lab
không có 8 foot model so we actually
publish if I would encourage that person
to actually email me I can get you the
table because we published six different
air flows for our general chemistry
hoods because they are high-performance
so we would publish at a fully open sash
and 18 inches open over the work surface
and at each of those points we publish
100
80 and 60 feet per minute so we have six
different published points so you know I
can either email that person or if they
if you want to email me just that best
em like Mary at lab comm cocom then that
would be W fine I can get you all that
information now that's what is the
difference between the echo and the
arrow dh3 chemical hoods that's a great
question because the only difference is
the size all of the technology is
identical all of the filters are
identical the arrow is 12 inches shorter
and it's offered in a three-foot version
and that 3 foot version is also offered
in a narrower depth to fit on a 30 inch
deep work surface so the only difference
is the size other than that you have the
same control box same filters same
everything so that's a great question
and it looks like we have no more
questions so we want to thank you again
Beth and do you have any final comments
for our audience just my final comment
if you have any questions please feel
free to reach out it's always better to
do a lot of research on the front end
before your purchase and and with this
equipment obviously it's not something
cheap to buy it's not like a pair of
gloves so our box of gloves so please
reach out I'm happy to answer any
questions
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today or those
submitted during the on demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information that you provided at
the time of registration we would like
to thank laborat and our sponsor lab
không có for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through February of
2019 leverage will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye